welcome back to cbs saturday morning
discipline focus and teamwork are
classic prescriptions for success
perhaps nowhere more so than in the
hard-working nation of japan but one man
has carved out his own strange path to
fame and fortune by doing quite the
opposite from tokyo lucy craft has the
story
most days shoji moriboto has
appointments with a steady stream of
clients
his service is as popular as it is
peculiar he bills himself the do-nothing
rent-a-man
i lend myself out to do nothing which
means i don't make any special effort he
said eating drinking or simple chit chat
that's about it
and that's enough for this customer who
requested anonymity for his mostly
female fans rent-a-man offers a safe
space no judgment no strings and on
request no talking
in japan women tend to worry about what
other people think about not being a
burden she said it's exhausting this
kind of escape is important
rent a man has struck a cord in this
workaholic and conformist country he's
collected almost a quarter of a million
followers on twitter
in his pre-slacker days morimoto bounced
aimlessly from one job to another out of
desperation and on a lark he decided to
rent himself out charging only for food
and car fare
thousands of encounters later
rent-a-man's experiences have earned him
royalties from four books including a
manga comic about joining clients at
museums in disneyland or providing moral
support for a divorcing spouse
his signature blue cap and backpack and
his inexplicable success inspired a
semi-fictional tv series last year
i have plenty of critics he said they
say get a job but i don't feel the need
to answer to anyone
his next client was 44 year old
healthcare worker tamami miyazaki
with my friends i'd obsess over whether
they might like the bar i chose she said
but with rent-a-man there's no drama
at 38 the father of one said he has no
plans to retire nothing's more fun he
says than doing nothing
for cbs saturday morning lucy craft
tokyo